le journaliste esquivé s'en sort sain et
sauf
annick devant le tribunal
[Musique]
son épouse et un député de tente de
maîtriser l'individu john doom da sans
fil protégé par un ami
l'homme cernés par des policiers en
civil fini par lâcher son arme
[Musique]
celui qui a diffusé cette information
risque de le payer très cher à laval à
prendre
la sphère des camions comme on l'appelle
ici est un scandale d'état
la diffusion de ces images il est
interdite et tous ceux qui ont enquêté
dessus qu'ils soient procureur gendarmes
ou journalistes ont tous été arrêtés en
direct sur les chaînes de télévision
pro-gouvernementales
est ce que la turquie a livré des armes
à des groupes djihadistes des groupes
islamistes en syrie non la réponse est
très simple
l'ex-chef des services secrets dément
formellement toute livraison d'armes en
syrie mais après 40 minutes d'entretien
la ligne de défense se fissure agacé par
nos questions il admet finalement
l'implication de ses services mais
refuse d'assumer seul la responsabilité
de cette opération
dans cet exercice il y a eu plusieurs
services de renseignements
écopant à tout le monde parle de mythes
qui vous dit que par exemple le service
de renseignements d'un autre pays
n'était pas impliqué dans cette affaire
mélissa je ne vous le dirais pas parce
que ça peut créer des problèmes sérieux
au niveau diplomatique
[Musique]
regrettez-vous avoir fourni autant
d'armes autant de munitions aux groupes
combattants islamistes et d'avoir laissé
passer autant de jihadistes en syrie
soit tu parles comme quelqu'un du fait
qu'avec leurs mêmes arguments je parle
comme journaliste pour du vouvoiement le
président ado one pass soudainement au
tutoiement une autre question nous vaut
d'être accusé de faire partie de fêter
une organisation classée comme
terroriste par le président turc
john tard il n'a été condamné qu'à une
peine de cinq mois de prison
quel est votre sentiment par rapport à
ça prend en compte mais c'est leur façon
à eux de nous punir les choses ce qu'ils
veulent c'est nous punir d'une façon ou
d'une autre en utilisant les voies
légales ou en se servant de gangsters en
caisse ou tout simplement nous censurant
ses associés il utilise tous les moyens
possibles pour nous punir